you know what's up I'm Robert DeLong I'm
in a live electronic music performer and
I'm going to show you how my rig is put
together here we go
this is the Gibraltar rack which holds
all my electronics each piece is one
fully labeled so you know exactly how it
goes together it's like Legos except
more expensive kind of when I realized I
was having nerdier than the rest was
when I got into programming and a pretty
young age the qbasic
simple ms-dos programming language and I
make text adventures
this right here is a beautifully made
keyboard mouse combo with USB hubs and
this is how I control my computers this
is actually made out of a cutlery
container
this right here it's a little road worn
but this is a custom piece made by livid
and it's a as you can see knob sliders
and some big arcade buttons and stuff
and this is just a MIDI controller that
no one else in the world has one like
this which is for better or worse I have
it this right here is a flight simulator
joystick what are the game controllers
that have repurposed in hacked so that
it can be a MIDI controller control
music these are all just stock
controllers that are you know USB or
bluetooth and turn whatever signals are
coming into your computer into something
totally different and so it's like some
really basic scripting
he's getting right here favorite pieces
equipment called the MIDI fighter it's
got some arcade buttons on it which is
cool with the coolest thing about it to
me is that it's had a gyro in it so you
can move things around and kind of a
sign how that changes the sound so last
thing I have is my wheel probably like a
15 year old it's a computer racing
hardware these are the brains of the
operation this is a Presonus mixing
console which is uh actually acts as my
converters for the computer so yeah it's
two two Mac minis right there and that's
what connects to all this stuff to make
make the magic happen
Oh
right here are my microphones for vocals
one of them is my main vocal mic the
other one have run effects when main
microphone one runs through a analog
print the knee 1073 if anybody's an
audio nerve you would know that all your
favorite albums have been recorded
through a 1073 everybody from nirvana to
Tom Petty to me
I'm Robert along I just played my tune
don't wait up here for a wire hope you
like it